hi everybody my name is Darius Kazemi I
I go by tiny subversions on the Internet
tiny subversions calm and tiny
subversions on Twitter I guess what I
want to talk about is I want to give you
a kind of an overview of some of the
stuff that I've done and I want to talk
about things that I've learned from
doing all this stuff first some brief
background on just my my own history my
my undergraduate degree was in
electrical engineering I never used it I
immediately went into the video game
industry not doing anything technical I
was a tester and then they figured out a
new math and so I immediately became one
of the first full-time data analysts for
online games in the country this was
back in 2006 and for a long time my
career was that sort of thing I was I
was analyzing players in online games
but I also liked to make games and so I
spent a lot of time trying to make my
own games on the side I've been
programming my whole life so you know it
wasn't it wasn't a huge it was a
technical challenge for me but I didn't
wasn't starting from zero the but over
time you know I just kept trying to put
out these different games and eventually
I discovered first I was just frustrated
that that when I built a game people
would have to download it and no one
wants to download things and then I so I
tried flash and I decided I hated flash
so I stopped then the first html5
browsers that supported canvas started
coming out in a late 2009 and what I
ended up doing was was jumping on the
bandwagon for some of the very earliest
html5 game engines and these were open
source projects I had no JavaScript
experience whatsoever no very little web
development experience and and I dove in
I started working on on
you know advanced for the time primitive
now game engines and that was fun and
then I ended up getting offered a
position at a company called beaucoup
doing html5 games technology and
projects and that sort of thing and so
that was my first time being hired
somewhere as a programmer up until that
point I'd been an analyst I'd been a
tester I'd been you know various kinds
of almost manager I guess but had never
been paid to write code before I learned
quickly cuz I had to at the company and
I was I was blessed to be surrounded by
people who were some of the best
open-source developers in the world so I
learned a lot and and in the time
working there my interests shifted away
from games I sort of went from games to
games in the browser to just the web
browser the web browser became this
incredibly interesting piece of software
for me particularly for creative
expression because that's all I ever
wanted to do with technology was to do
was to express myself or express ideas
creatively through technology and as I
started learning all these skills I
started learning oh I can start messing
with the internet itself like I can mess
with websites that I use everyday I can
mess around with api's I can do that I
knew I'd known that that was possible
you know I'd seen mashups and funny apps
and things like that before but all of a
sudden I had those skills and I was
being paid to learn and develop them
every day so so in my we got I think
something but something like a fifth of
our week was devoted to open source
projects and so I would just spend two
hours every morning working on weird art
projects of various kinds via so I guess
I'll just start by talking about some of
my my earlier work one of the earliest
things that I built was a Twitter bot I
make a lot of these
or in it this one's called a metaphor a
minute and and this is the first Twitter
bot that I built it was technically the
second but this was the first and sort
of my recent crop so I did this in May
2012 I've only been at this for three
and a half years and this just tweets
one metaphor every two minutes at the
time that I built this BOTS Twitter rate
limits were such that if you tweeted one
per minute it would go over the rate
limit so and it's very simple it's very
that's sort of a mad libs style thing a
noun is a noun an adjective but
adjective and I actually wrote this as a
there's an academic his name is Ian
Bogost and he wrote a book called alien
phenomenology which I had read in April
of 2012 and it's it's a philosophy book
and but one of the provocations in the
book is that maybe we can do philosophy
not just by writing writing is certainly
writing and speaking are certainly ways
to do philosophical work but
philosophical work can also be done and
arguments can be made through the
creation of objects and so I didn't like
something that he had to say about
metaphor I thought he was leaning too
heavily on the concept of metaphor in
the book so I decided to write this bot
as my response instead of writing a blog
post and I sent it to him and he's he
still follows it right down there in the
corner and and this thing's tweeted
almost a million metaphors since May of
2012 and my favorite thing is when
poetry magazines like actually find this
bot and like retweet it I love it you
know there's a new one and then there's
it has interesting emergent properties
when I started following it it tweets
every two minutes and ever since May
2012 I've had this constant heartbeat on
Twitter I always know when two minutes
have passed between one tweet and
another because there's a metaphore
minute tweet sort of sitting there as
like a milestone marker and some people
are like yeah it's really like I don't
even see it anymore you know obviously
you don't have to follow it if you don't
want something tweeting every two
minutes in your timeline but it's
usually innocuous
time's funny and most the time I don't
even notice it I just register on this
subconscious level of Oh two minutes had
passed Oh two minutes have passed
I've been reading Twitter for ten
minutes I should probably stop and and I
did not design that into meta form in it
but one of the things I love about
putting things out into ecosystems like
social network sites is often these
emergent properties that I did not even
design into the software appear and and
this is the same reason why I liked
making games was I liked the emergent
properties that would come up when you
give a game to users and they discover
things about it that you did not intend
in your design but are still like
wonderful and amazing things and but the
best part about this is I don't need to
teach someone how to use a Twitter bot
like I know if you're on Twitter you
already know how to follow it and you
already know how to read it and it might
be a little confusing to you but it's
not like a game where I would have to
teach you what the controls are and how
to use it and you go through a tutorial
and all of those things I can just build
the interesting part the part that is
interesting to me and then just give it
to the audience so so I've been like
team weird internet stuff for a long
time and and haven't really done games
for quite some time
I like to open my talks with a magic
trick and forgive me if you've seen this
one before
here it is so this is something sort of
like a question that I like to pose to
an audience so okay if I asked you to
build a joke generator would you say
that's a trivial problem like something
that consistently generates new jokes
and makes people laugh anyone no okay
yeah it's probably not trivial if I ask
you to build an algorithm that grabs a
random noun and its dictionary
definition would you say that's trivial
yeah
yeah it is right and so and so I have
something running here a typewriter a
writing machine that produces characters
similar to typeset print by means of etc
etc you know solicitude the state of
being solicitous apostrophe the
superscript sign used to indicate the
omission of a letter consultation the
act or process of consulting alright
the magic trick is that I don't have to
do any computational work at all to turn
this into a joke generator all I have to
do is this girl you must be a
consultation because you are the act or
process of consulting girl you must be
propulsion because you are the process
of driving or propelling girl he must be
a porcelain because you are hard white
translucent ceramic made by firing a
pure clay and then glazing it with
various colored fusible materials for
example China and so this is this this
has become a joke generator with no
computational tricks up my sleeve all I
did was put a picture of Ryan Gosling
and nine words around the simple trivial
algorithm of grabbing a dictionary
definition and putting it on a screen
and so one of the things and this is
this is actually again something that I
learned from my time in games which is
that faking it can be as good or better
than simulating something I very very
hard to make everything I do as
computationally simple as possible
I love losing myself in fancy algorithms
and that sort of thing but I try to make
things simple
partly because I only have so much time
on this earth and I'd like to put out I
put out one project a week roughly and
and I get a lot of mileage out of that I
enjoy that way more than if I spent a
year working on a project and then
released it that's just part of my own
creative process but similarly you know
what's robust simple code you know it's
not robust
complex code you know what has lots of
bugs complex code you know what has not
a lot of bugs
simple code anything and just trying to
figure out as many ways as I can to just
scope the project down scope it down
continually until there's nothing left
but this like hard Jim this hard white
translucent ceramic of an idea so so
yeah I mentioned I have a lot of
projects this is this is my projects
list on tiny submergence comm there's a
lot of stuff that I'd built generally
speaking it's in a few different
categories of most broadly speaking
there are websites that generate content
sort of like where I just put on the
screen and and then there are bus and
basically I consider the difference
between a bot and a website that
generates content they both generate
content but to me a bot is something
that you know interacts with humans on
human terms so so it's it's sitting in
an IRC channel and communicating through
IRC just the way that a human would or
it's on Twitter and communicating that
way and it's just this this flattening
of the terms of communication it's as
flattening of the terms of communication
so I'll show some of my better known
projects this is maybe my best-known
project it's called random shopper it's
a a bot that doesn't live on a social
network but it's a bot that I gave a $50
Amazon gift card once a month and it
bought me things at random and shipped
them to me blind
and so the output of the project was
these packages of the peer at my home
and then I would take pictures of them
and sort of unbox them and try to read
the books and things that it sent me and
and sometimes weird and wonderful things
would happen the bot sent me a wonderful
little book of poetry called
bewilderment by David Ferrie I also got
this book this book is kind of special
it's called palmistry
for all its by this guy Cairo he was a
well-known palm reader from the early
20th century he was like super super
like he's like Kanye West famous in the
1910s and and so this is like a
best-seller back in the day so palmistry
for all it's actually a creative common
it's it's in the public domain excuse me
because it was published before 19 26 I
want to say and it's also so because
it's on public domain it's on Project
Gutenberg and because it's on Project
Gutenberg there are algorithms that
scraped Project Gutenberg and there are
entire publishing houses that are purely
algorithmic on Amazon you go to their
Amazon profile and they have three
hundred thousand books that they have
published and it is all books that you
can find for free on Project Gutenberg
this is one of them and their entire
business model is if you're searching
for you know Tale of Two Cities
maybe you'll buy their Tale of Two
Cities instead of the penguin edition
you know or if you're certain or if you
happen to be searching for a very old
book and you don't know any better to
think what if it's just for free online
already or like you I guess who really
want a paper copy then you buy their
Edition now of course no one lays these
things out these are all laid out by
programs and print it on demand so you
get things like this let me see if I can
make it here's our rare reprints
thousands of scarce and hard-to-find
books like those they are hard to find
it's that's true the book is also it's a
book about palm reading it has very
important diagrams all over it and none
of them are in this edition it's just
look do you figure a there's no figure a
so it's a book about palm reading with
no diagrams and that wasn't something
that I designed into it either but it
turns out that if you randomly sample
the collection of books on Amazon you
are highly likely to receive a book that
a computer
and published so so this is like a
computer buying a book from another
computer that was trying to scam the
computer into giving someone who's not a
computer my money so that's that was
random shopper
this one's called reverse OCR I noticed
last summer it was almost a year ago
this last August that someone had
released a an OCR optical character
recognition algorithm in JavaScript and
I work in JavaScript everything that I
do is either nodejs on the server or
JavaScript on the front end it's simply
because I don't know any better and the
so this algorithm is it's it's the
classic tesseract OCR algorithm just
wrapped up for a web browser so it's
it's an old algorithm it's not very good
and I started playing with it it had a
little demo space and I just noticed wow
this is full of weird false positives so
I thought well what if I could elicit
false positives from the OCR algorithm
and so what I did was I wrote a bot that
basically just takes it makes little
squiggles here's here's a here's a a
gallery piece that I did based on
reversed OCR and you can see that it
thinks this thing is a 3 it thinks this
thing is a Z that's a Z so that's
actually pretty good it's got the
forward slash there it thinks there's a
bracket in here and it's just trying to
find the letter L and it's just gonna go
until it finds the letter L and then
it's going to move on to a and this is
exactly what my bot does it's not smart
if it finds a before L it doesn't care
it just keeps going this is because I
wrote this program not the one you're
seeing here this took a little longer
but that's this is because I wrote this
program in two and a half hours and just
publish it on the internet because I
have a life and don't have time to write
code that is incredibly performant when
it doesn't have to be you know this is
these are this is a bot this is posting
something to tumblr every six hours so
as long as it takes less than six hours
for me to do an atomic
thing that's fine so I really don't care
if I'm doing something if something
could be optimized by an order of
magnitude or two orders of magnitude or
whatever because that's not the problem
space that I'm working in here it allows
me to work quickly and allows me to to
no cheat I guess
so that's that's reverse OCR I'll go
through kind of like the Greatest Hits
here I guess this piece is called
content forever this actually came out
of a project that I do every year I've
done it for two years running this
coming November will be the third time
it's called nanogen MO who here is
familiar with NaNoWriMo okay
a few people NaNoWriMo has been
happening on the internet for about 10
years it is called National Novel
Writing Month it's not national anymore
it's international but they kept the
name because I NaNoWriMo does not flow
off the tongue quite as easily so um
yeah no rhyme oh it happens every
November and the the NaNoWriMo whole
thing is anyone can write a novel and
what they say is spend the month they
challenge people to spend the month of
November writing a novel and they define
a novel as 50,000 words of whatever
which is a really interesting definition
of a novel to me you know you go to an
English department and ask them what a
novel is you're gonna get a whole range
of answers none of which are probably
bound to length almost at all but I
thought it was a really interesting
constraint normally I work in a Twitter
constraint where I have 140 characters
at a time and I thought it would be
really fun to flex some muscles and see
if I could build something that kept
people's attention for longer than 140
characters it's an entirely different
problem space and so nanogen mo it
happens every year nanogen mo i'll just
here's the 2014 one it happens on github
it just happens in an issues or paws
torie and you open up a thread that's
your declaration to participate and and
then everyone participates so some
people use these as Diaries and these
are a bunch of completed entries here's
the quantum supposition of Oz with
people commenting on it it's a nice
community we have a great resources
thread as well I think I linked it from
the main repo here yes hope an issue for
resources and we have resources spreads
every year and so this is just a huge
Fred full of natural language processing
resources that people can can use or
various corpuses that people can draw on
and so last year I did not actually
complete any nanogen mill projects I had
a few that I had started working on it
didn't go anywhere but one of those
projects was a novel about someone who
was staying up late at night reading
Wikipedia and it was essentially a
first-person narrative I opened
Wikipedia
I saw a link for Stephen Colbert I
clicked on the link I read the article I
saw a link for Comedy Central I clicked
on let you know and and that wasn't very
good to say the least
so I put it aside I didn't release it
but I had the code lying around and and
then eventually I got this idea I was
reading a terrible meandering essay
about technology on medium I was just
awful and and I thought oh I could
probably use that Wikipedia algorithm
that I built to generate awful essays I
can't write code to generate great
essays that's hard but generating awful
essays is easy and fun and and so this I
can I do minutes of content because I'm
writing on medium here so give me 20
minutes of content on Stanford
University go okay
Stanford University of history other
some nyan politics include UN Ambassador
Susan Rice former Secretary of Defense
and current Stanford professor William
Perry former US ambassador Afghanistan
and Karl Eikenberry former US and then
my regular expression fails the Senate
supported a resolution that said the
violence in Benghazi can coincided with
an attack on the United States embassy
in Cairo Egypt blah blah blah then we
and it starts talking about this ardent
social conservative oh yeah trey Gowdy
so we're gonna talk about trey Gowdy
here who's who's pro-life and now we're
going to talk about US Congress
congressional appropriations bills and
then the impro creation and impressed
supply bill and then a little bit about
democratic appropriation in general and
then we talk about the West Minister
parlous parliamentary system in Terry's
system because you know we're talking
about governments now and then we're
going to talk about Acts of Parliament
and then the United Kingdom in general
and so on and so forth until you know 20
minutes later we're talking about
standard definition television ratios
mathematical quotients we're back to the
United Kingdom again that's cool Ireland
yeah and then and then we end on tax
incentives so yes I'm grandmotherly what
where's the text like it's the actual
procedure the seizure is this see oops
hopefully this is online this actually
does a few extra things as well mmm
looks like it's offline right now it's
walking through Wikipedia is all to
doing so it's it looks at the first you
give it a topic it goes to the page for
that topic it binds it it's bound to the
first five or ten paragraphs of that
article it picks a paragraph at random
it displays the text for that paragraph
it picks a link from that paragraph and
then goes to the next page so it's just
walking through Wikipedia and finding
you know just just collecting text as it
goes yeah
the images are also from the Wikipedia
articles so it happens too to find an
article with images on it it will grab
that image as well and as well as well
as well as the caption for it so it's
it's it's scraping Wikipedia just in a
sort of just like just like the my magic
trick was was sort of scraping a
dictionary and then adding extra context
around it this is scraping Wikipedia and
also adding extra context the other
contextual trick here is I stole mediums
CSS so this is this is formatted like a
medium article which which I liked very
much there was a little uh uh oh come on
oh my my shortcuts aren't working that's
okay
and I actually if you're interested you
can go to the website for this and I
build most of this in jsfiddle so I
actually had access to every single
revision of the project and so I did
like an sort of like a director's
commentary so if you're interested you
can go through and see all the different
design considerations that went into
creating this over time another one I
think this one's my most popular Twitter
body this is definitely my most popular
Twitter bot this is the sorting hat bot
it's the sorting hat from Harry Potter
and you follow it and it puts you in a
queue and it sorts you into Harry Potter
house and it comes up with a unique
rhyme just for you but sorting hat is
who I am I'm watching when you plow so I
deduced that Gryffindor is the right
place for your Frau I am the cruel
sorting hat I know each time you shout
it's plain to see that hufflepuffs the
house to put your clout let's see
I am the gorgeous sorting hat look upon
my facts today you join with Raven claw
because your waist is lacks your wrist
is spare your tongue insane yet you are
so decayed from this authentic recipe a
ravenclaw is made and so that was that
was like a culmination of a whole number
of different projects so this is
actually I didn't just sit down and make
the sorting hat the first thing that I
made a year before I made sorting hat
was this thing called every nerd and and
this is a comprehensive list of all
nerds worldwide Nerdist
by someone who follows every nerd and
this was a play on on every word which
is my friend Alison's famous Twitter bot
that tweeted every word in the English
language in alphabetical order for five
years so every nerd you can follow it
you'll get up on there and everywhere
was my first time using a persistent
Redis store to sort of track state in a
bot and use like a queueing system and
that was it so like the you know this
project creatively was like nothing but
it was sort of a creative no op but but
I did do this interesting infrastructure
thing as part of it and then the next
thing that came after that was was
working with Rita Jas Rita Jas is a an
excellent natural language library most
natural language processing libraries
are built for analysis Rita is built for
generation so it's actually designed for
artists and writers who want to create
new works this is very different from
something like n LT K which is much more
meant for consuming large corpuses of
language and inferring computational
things about them and it's a great it's
a great library there's all sorts of
good stuff around you know a number of
syllables and stresses of syllables and
meter and rhyme and all those things and
so um and so I started playing with Rita
and another project and then just one
day I got the idea oh I saw I had a
friend on Twitter who was sorting people
that was her sort of shtick you know you
would you would ask her to sort you into
a sorting into into a house from Harry
Potter and she would sort you and she
would say why and so I was like oh I
could do that and so I built yeah so I
built this some this bot that sorts
people and I have and again if you're
interested from the bio I linked a
technical article on how how it works
how I did it
and some of the some of the design
considerations that went into it here's
a funny thing
Gryffindor Ravenclaw Hufflepuff
Slytherin they all have a 101 meter so
that made my my life a lot easier I
didn't have to I could just I could just
do that and I would just pick a house
and slot it into the rhyme and that was
that it doesn't do anything smart to
determine what house you're in that's
more of my commentary on the sorting hat
from the Harry Potter series itself so
let me close out some windows here yeah
and then and then there's uh there's I
do a lot of other stuff and it's usually
quick projects this one was I found a
I've known these existed for a while but
someone finally released a good reverse
regular expression algorithm for the
browser or a library for the browser and
so what this does is you give it a
regular expression and then it returns a
string that a random string that
satisfies the regular expression so if I
did you know digit digit and then said
generate it's like 79-68 92 64 that sort
of thing and so you know if I did
something more complex then you know I
can get these weird words and and what
you can do with something like this you
can do all sorts of things but let me
reload this so it's a little better yeah
and so there's a concept in linguistic
called called an isogloss
map and this is a map maybe you've seen
them it'll say like different you know I
think I actually linked to it here yes
this is probably easier so these are
maps that talk about where different
linguistic like syllables and sounds and
that sort of thing exists in a
geographic area and so a sort of a way
of mapping how language has moved from
one place to another over time
historically and what I wanted to do was
use the reverse regular expression
generator and sort of turn that on it's
every one of these circles is a set of
syllables
this one is Alba's kha and this one is X
back puck and so a city that would be
within both of these would have some
combination of those syllables in its
name yeah here's yeah here's a towards a
good this isn't the greatest map they
make a new one oh I thought like this
right I just added this to generate a
new map so like the stuff out in the
countryside has these very short names
that all sounds sort of similar Jojo
Foshee Foggia FIFA and then in the
middle you know if you happen to be at a
linguistic crossroads you get these
really long complicated names but what
it does is you can place cities
arbitrarily on a map and there will be a
kind of sense to how they appear because
cities that are close to each other will
have linguistically similar names and
you wouldn't have a language that is
entirely foreign to another language for
like for like for like some civilization
right so this is this is a this was a
prototype for what could be a map
generation system was it was it came out
of discussions with a friend of mine who
was a game developer who wanted to build
a civilization style game using
completely new civilizations all the
time but there that's just this is this
very simply comes out of this reverse
regular expression concept and something
that I always like to tell people
especially in computer science is that
if you have a tool whose purpose is to
analyze something like a regular
expression right like that's that's like
this tool that we typically use to to
analyze text to categorize it to extract
things from it but any tool for analysis
you can press the reverse key you press
the reverse button and feed noise into
it and then it becomes a tool for
creativity and so I always like to
stress that so whenever I see I'm always
really happy like I subscribe to all
sorts of newsletters about what new
libraries are coming out and Java
Java scripting that sort of thing and
every single one I see I think does this
have the potential to you know be a be
some kind of a filter for a generator
and if it does I'll try and sit down and
do something with it yeah you know
greedy case-insensitive
that sort of stuff so it's that it's the
modifiers you can add to most regular
expressions for for things like that I
also believe really strongly and giving
people tools to do stuff even if they
don't even if they aren't programmers
this is based on idea that a friend
scott scott john seagull of mine had
this is a text generator designer that
all you need to do is use google
spreadsheets to build it and so the way
that you would do it is so this is a
simple game idea generator but I'll just
make a new one right now oh thanks
google yeah I definitely want insights
very helpful let's clone this and then
I'm just gonna take let's delete okay
come on we'll delete all the B's so I'll
make it bigger so we can actually read
it
title new project author me let's see
let's do I don't know so let's put some
salutations in there hi hello hey let's
make that normalized a what's up then
we'll just make this one have you heard
that I don't know let's do some I don't
know celebrities Kanye West will bring
Kanye back into this Madonna
who else celebrity come on Miley just
Miley we'll just go with Miley well
we'll do that that's fine have you heard
that you know gave a speech gave a no
speech drunken rant I will just will
will acceptance speech lecture baby
that's gonna that's gonna bite us in the
ass
this morning that was so what amazing
great well just will stop here because
you can see where this is going and so
all you have to do is publish this to
the web publish the entire document yes
I want to publish the whole thing take
this URL actually I don't even take that
URL I take this URL and paste it in here
and then suddenly hey have you heard the
Kanye West gave a baby this morning that
was so amazing hey hi have you heard
that Madonna gave an acceptance speech
this morning that was so amazing and you
know it's it's clunky you have to design
around a and and and things like that
but that's not super hard to do and and
you can it gives you a link but you
don't have to host anything anywhere
it's just all happens through having the
document key in the top of the in the
URL bar up there and there are there are
tons of people who have used this tool
to make these really intricate text
generators and they're not programmers
at all but they do know how to use
Google Google Spreadsheets and so that
was very gratifying and I was really
happy to provide that to people and then
what happened was someone else made
where is it
what's his well someone else forked the
project and made something that actually
built could build a Twitter bot
Google Spreadsheets and so you would put
your your OAuth keys in the spreadsheet
and there was actually a Google Apps
Script that would hook up and run the
bot in the background for you and it was
much more complicated than my thing but
it was great because it was essentially
the same project in terms of you know
composing the bot but it made it very
easy for people to create combinatoric
Twitter BOTS and so and so sometimes
these tools get forked and turned into
other things and that's always been very
gratifying to me as well
I guess what I want to do right now oh
and while I'm on tools I also publish
tools to build this sort of stuff this
is a this is a grunt init template that
I just used to scaffold a new Twitter
bot so so if I want a new thing new
thing grunt in its Twitter bot and then
it walks me through am I gonna do any
screens great thing no am I gonna make
HTTP requests no project name sure new
thing description I don't know
version all these other things word Nick
API key I'm not going to use word Nick
for this I know my Twitter keys I'll
just put garbage in there right now and
then I have you know I have a whole you
know project already scaffold it and
right now it is a oops
right now install my stuff to do yeah I
know I
thanks NPM
right now just oh I know it's broken
right now because I just upgraded node
but you get the idea it's a it's a full
you know it's a full scaffold for for a
Twitter bot project and so this also
helps me get my project out very very
quickly I try to make sure that I'm
never doing the same thing twice because
I'm not getting paid to do any of this
stuff so why would I ever bother so oh
and then other quick hacks does this one
actually work this does work you know a
company released the old DOS game
Wolfenstein 3d and they made it work in
the web browser and and that was cool
and so I scraped the whole thing and
started running it on my own server and
and literally all I did was replace all
the wall textures with a video from call
of duty so every every texture in the
game is now this animated gif this took
like five minutes this is why I love the
Internet
because oh because I can just do things
like that and in a few minutes because
it's really like you can just you can
just rip things apart when I teach when
I teach kids how to program the first
thing that I do is I open up the I open
up the the developer console and I show
them how to just start removing elements
that they don't like from a website and
they love that and I show them how to
like you know change titles of things my
friend Mike is a poophead yeah you know
and and they love that and so and so I
try to like show kids that you can that
the web is this weird fungible thing
that you can do all this amazing stuff
with with very little you just it's a
bit esoteric you have to know that if
you go to inspect element this thing
pops up it's there it's right there if
you use Chrome or Firefox it is or any
browser really it's right there for you
but it's just you know
talks about it but every single you know
if every single human being with chrome
on a desktop has access to literally an
entire IDE with a console and an editor
and a local file system and a debugger
and you know stack traces and and all
that sort of stuff you know before it
was like well do you have Visual Studio
installed yes or no you know and that
was the difference but everybody has a
full IDE on their machine now and that's
exciting to me and that's part of what
I'm trying to work with on this sort of
stuff so I don't want to talk too much
longer because we don't have that much
more time so I think I'd like to do is
just open up to more general questions
I'm happy to answer questions happy to
go through other projects or or anything
right at the end you mentioned something
I'm interested in just teaching kids to
program yeah when I learned to program
it was like on the 6502 basic modern
program is way more intimidating
seems like javascript is a great way to
go yeah I think javascript is look the
best thing about JavaScript is its
concrete it's not abstract at least when
it's in the web browser it's it's
attached to these websites and things
that you use every single day yes you do
yeah I think Chrome generally has the
best developer tools although Firefox
did just release their developer edition
of Firefox but then again that involves
involved installing new software so you
know Safari is safaris WebKit is its
WebKit inspector so it's it's similar on
the back end as well I think chrome is
like you know if you've gave me a choice
I mean I develop on a Chromebook so if
you give me a choice I would be
developing in Chrome but but every every
web browser doesn't good enough
certainly for a for a kid process I mean
you said when I teach kids is if you do
here pretty regularly yeah you talked
about that a little bit I mean it's all
mentorship so I usually you know scale
it to the
the kid so yeah yeah so you talked about
this really cool concept of converting
an analyzer and getting a generator and
and perhaps an artistic choice that you
work with noise randomness and that
gives you you know totally original
totally random content um do you ever
experiment with with using sources on
the other side of that generator that
aren't noise and and getting something
different out of it like instead of
scraping you know all of what to pedia
you do something somatic like scrape
write articles with George Bush or
whatever well so so almost nothing is
actually noise right like like all noise
has a color to it all noise has a unique
shape in in the frequency domain and so
when you're when you're looking at noise
sources they're all going to be slightly
different when I compose using actually
I can bring this up I'm glad you brought
this up because I have something
prepared for this doo-doo-doo this is
just for another talk just I mean my old
employer there yeah here it is so like I
often think about generating text the
way that you might think about
generating using noise based synthesis
you've got this this this noise input
you maybe have a pulse generator as well
that you use to shape things with and so
literally I see noise as like the
Twitter public feed if I'm using Twitter
and a pulse generator might be something
like like Rita which has sort of like
understanding of the way language is
shaped and then I'm literally running
filters on everything if I pull up the
source code for I don't know let's see
what's a good example here here we go
dialogue jokes dialogue jokes is ended
up being this this bot called um weird
convo bot I noticed this one this one
joke format appear on Twitter over and
over so I was like I can generate that
and so it's like dog are you an Internet
vape me BAE what the
dog i skateboard playing with bey me
same different satan SM age and and
and what that does is and that's
literally you know if I go to the go to
the actual source here so so this is so
so this is my my pulse generator I've
got these pulses of Satan and skateboard
and and ghost and weed and then I also
have this this search function here
which is just searching the Twitter
public feed but I'm immediately
filtering the public feed I'm searching
for phrases that contain do you are you
would you can you and so the public feed
is noise I'm immediately shaping that
using this search I'm also injecting
these pulses in the form of this
language that I already want in there
and then it's literally what's happening
here is hold on where it's in its in the
actual search function itself here it is
and literally when I do the search I'm
doing maps and reduces and and rejecting
certain terms and and injecting certain
terms and that sort of thing so I'm
literally just going through this white
noise and saying okay remove these bits
of language add these bits of language
and and it literally ends up looking in
my head something like this is the sort
of program flow and and so and so I
sometimes I like to think about things
in terms of additive synthesis which is
like it would be the equivalent of of
sculpting but rather like building with
blocks and then and then subtractive
synthesis which is sculpting where you
remove things from a piece of marble or
that sort of thing and and noise when
you run excuse me pardon me for my my
slides here you know you run noise
through a filter and you get sound and
so I think if you take a corpus and you
run it through a filter you get writing
and honestly I think this is how real
writing works too right no one's ever
been a writer who's never read before
right
and so and and you know when I do when I
sit down to write an essay I'm drawing
on the corpus of literally everything
I've ever experienced in my life
and I am this filter and then writing
comes out the other end you know in a
very real sense this is something that
that that matters to me and and when you
talk about sources that are sort of non
noise I actually it's a good chance to
bring up corpora which is a project that
I started a couple years ago and I
maintain it and it is just a github
repository full of corpuses of small
corpuses of data so corporations here's
a list of cars ok Nasdaq here's all the
companies on the Nasdaq newspapers a
list of newspapers and so on and so it's
kind of like those lists on Wikipedia
but in JSON and machine readable format
and it's all public domain and so a lot
of people use corpora as the basis for
their projects as kind of like that
pulse generator well instead of noise
yeah doesn't make me laugh so question
was what what's the what's the metric
that I use for the success of these
projects and the metric is doesn't make
me laugh and if it does then the project
is a success also did I finish it
quickly if I finished it quickly the
project is a success the longer the
project took me to make the more I
consider it a failure the more it makes
the less it makes me laugh the more I
consider it a failure there are other
metrics that are secondary like actual
popularity so you know number of Twitter
followers is a rough metric you know and
my my Google Analytics traffic on my
sites and that sort of thing I look at
that stuff too but there are project
there are some of these things I love
that nobody else seems to like but I
still consider them wildly successful
here's one this one was a bot called for
my real friends bilingual handyman for
my former lover former handyman for my
bilingual lover incredible companionship
for my canine dogs canine companionship
for my incredible dogs and this just
makes me laugh every time I see you on
Twitter and so I consider that project a
six
it has like a hundred followers or
something is which is not a lot for one
of my projects but it's still a success
because it took me an afternoon and it
makes me laugh yes have you considered
or have you done anything sort of
real-time because I've noticed over the
last 10 years people's attention spans
beginning shorter and shorter to the
point where now people's attention spans
are effectively zero so they want to see
things grow and change right in front of
them so have you done anything like
where you take the live feed from
Twitter the posts and just like sort of
a refresh rate about one second so
you're looking at things that are
happening right now in the world or
you're looking at the data that's
happening right now in the world and
morphing that yeah I've done things like
that at like a refresh rate of one per
second but I also don't see how that's
too different from from a regular
Twitter bot I have that it's something
like two headlines here which if China
is collapsing nobody told Joe Biden
oculus rift beats Suarez Navarro to
reach quarters in Tokyo Nickelodeon to
bring back facebook programming
non-political Kareem abdul-jabbar
confirms run for 2020 presidency Watson
the IBM supercomputer joins tech elite
in Obama move so like I quite like the
experiment you showed before with the
OCR processor and you could watch it
like drawing out in front of you that's
what I mean by real-time but again they
have a real-time architecture but I
always typically what I do is when I'm
exploring the aesthetic space of the
project my natural instinct is to crank
up the the real time this and then once
it starts being super real time it loses
aesthetic coherence to me humans aren't
super good like if I was building
something for robots as my audience I
would totally do something in real time
because robots love real-time
information humans not so much humans
like the filters they like you know
they we haha yeah we like filters and we
like we don't like information overload
generally speaking actually one of my
least favorite you know I have another
slide deck I'll just pull it up I'm just
you know let's just let's do this let's
do this since you brought it up
so you know I gave this talk a while
back called composing for infinity and I
have to go through all of this you know
I think I can do a skip to slide 20 or
something almost there
bear with me here Oh internet my my
issue with stuff that is real-time is it
tends to have incredible mathematical
beauty to it right so so rightly here's
here's some pseudocode while true print
math dot random congratulations
I've just created more content than you
could ever consume in your entire life
it's all unique have at it right like
sit down sit down and read this and if
you do read it you will be reading it
for the rest of your life and it took me
two lines of code and three seconds to
write and code is is very very strange
and I think that when we only try to do
something mathematically beautiful with
computer art we end up producing stuff
like this is a painting by Thomas
Kincade who is this kind of commercial
painter who paints these sort of
realistic scenes that lots of people
like but are not terribly interesting as
art they're they're sort of they're
pretty they're decorative objects and
similarly I feel that way about Markov
chains I feel that way about fractal
based generation algorithms I see it so
on the Left we have just some Markov
soup it's going
Hamlet right now to die to suffer the
insolence of time who would bear the
pale cast of death what is there to
sleep other to bear thought and scorns
of action it feels like language but
it's not interesting
similarly this this thing on the right
that someone wrote is uh it's just
Perlin noise generating a landscape and
it when you look at it it's pretty and
it does have that sense of being a
landscape but once you've seen three of
them you go I'm bored and you know show
me something else now and and so I see
these things as isomorphic to one
another one is happening in a language
space and one is happening in sort of a
more simulated physical space and so
yeah I'm not super big on real time
because I just feel like it's I'm really
really really concerned with readability
and the stuff that I build that's why I
try to reduce the complexity first of
all and then also I try not to overload
people with information and you might
say that like my projects are extremely
you know on the nose or you know I've
gotten fair criticism that they're just
that they're just too simple or
something like that and that's fine I'd
much rather have that criticism and
certain other criticisms well well I'll
point pull up this is my this is
something I released two days ago or you
know ten days ago ten days ago wow it's
been a long time this is called the
ethical ad blocker it is a Chrome
extension and what it does is it
determines when an ad is on a website
and if there's an ad on the website it
prevents you from seeing the website so
for example let me pull up my extensions
here I'll just I'll enable it
oh I don't I don't have my own extension
installed hold on
I'll install it it's on the Chrome Web
Store I'll add it here it's already on
Chrome enable it there we go okay so you
know I'm going to you know Wikipedia I
can I can learn about cats that's fine
let's go to the New York Times oh sorry
it's ad support it would be unethical to
view all right well the internet
Engineering Task Force is not ad
supported so I can I can view RFC's all
day long if I like that's cool
let's see Stanford University oh this is
that's a researcher at Stanford and hold
on Stanford
okay Stanford's site that's good we can
click around and look at the academics
awesome good not a lot of university
websites actually passed muster on this
filter and and what and what this
project was was well let's search Google
and oh no what this what this project
was was adblock plus is open source and
so I just worked at block plus I found
where it was detecting ads and just
injected some code that popped you over
to a page instead of blocking yet so
again that was like a very
that's like again it's like that simple
but readable project I just find I find
readability so key because the worst
thing for me is when I walk into I my
gets so excited every time I'm about to
walk into an art gallery and they're
showing you know technical art of some
kind or another it's very exciting to me
and then I and then I go in there and uh
you know nine times out of ten I look
around and I go I don't understand what
any of this is trying to say to me and
maybe that's me maybe I'm just not good
at reading art but you know I I think
I think this kind of stuff should be
somewhat readable and accessible I don't
want to have to read the artists
statement to understand why something is
good I like reading artist statements
but I want to already like it and then
read the artist statement and then like
it even more you know that's the that's
the that's the key for me and so yeah I
just think that information overload
stuff yeah there's actually a great term
that was coined fairly recently I forget
who coined it but the idea was it was a
data ISM data is embitterment where the
primary aesthetic quality of the art is
that it looks like data and so you know
Minority Report and you have all these
you know windows flying everywhere or
those those graphs of the Internet right
like like big spaghetti graph things
graph visualizations and all that sort
of stuff that's those are all examples
of data ISM I wish I could remember who
coined that Moritz Stefan or appointed
me to it but I don't know who he got it
from anyway so he has a long way to
answer to your question
you